wuih
I don't let these shortcomings
limit my steps forward to
pursue my dreams
I hope that all
people not only see my shortcomings
but see my work
hi hi
Hi my name goes forward because of this I am
a photographer
I was born without hands and  my feet
chose to be a photographer at first
I became an ID card photographer in
my village and I thought photography was
interesting
[Music]
I used a small Gokart car which
I called the F1 car I
assembled I designed my own and
that car took me where  -where
until now
I use a camera
with one of the meats that is still
given by God, the
meat is left and this meat is what I use
to
press the shutter then
I use my left hand to hold the
weight of the camera
[Music]
My photos are published maybe not
only in Indonesia but also yesterday there were
several international media
Then there are  some of my photos are
also published in Turkey my followers are
almost there I want to help
friends who have the desire
to learn photography I hope
that those who get photography inspiration are
not only people in
normal quotes but friends with
disabilities
[Music]
but me
I'm proud of my limitations
I think I'm disabled but
I'm not a disabled person
but I'm just a person who
[music]
wuih
when we can be used to access
public transportation it's very difficult
because I'm also a person with a disability so that
I want to give something to
my friends about the problems we
face regarding transportation.
My name is Triono as the founder
and CEO of our transport department. Of course,
one culprit is disabled.
All of that goes to and we prioritize
services for friends with disabilities.
Maybe if we calculate it, we have already
delivered  from
2015/2017 Thousands of people who have  We
have managed to mobilize special needs,
even friends whose terms are in
remote areas, we can mobilize
the passenger identification number, blue number,
stage, time, place, and the
needs we have to provide,
we have two types of motorbikes, yes, one
single ship is only for the other
seat.  for the military for wheelchairs
Hi
before us these divas walked they
couldn't move they ended up getting depressed
first we just thought it was simple we can
take them where they go and go home
again We never imagined the
impact would be this big so it's not that
amazing good we
hi
hu
almost a hundred  percent of the whole
body is black even
the internal organs are black like
bones and meat everything is black
My name is wirakusuma I raise chicken
cemani in Indonesia
[Music]
for the first person to see chicken
cemani tudia one must be surprised he was amazed the
first time I saw him I was amazed I was
shocked because since  small we already know
there is Aya  m, the black chicken exists, but
we have never met. Well,
when I was grown up, I was given three.
being a very black chicken,
by the way, the
price of cemani chicken varies
depending on the quality, now
the price is around 10-20 million which
Hai's money brings profits and brings
peace and
prosperity to the owner.
this chicken,
but indeed we have a
chemistry relationship, it is a relationship between the mind
and the chicken when we are stressed and
sick again. Not feeling well. Thoughts
sometimes the chickens are also stressed, they
don't want to eat, if we are
happy, the father is also happy, for me, I
want to raise cemani chickens, there is one
pride and for me  As an
Indonesian citizen, this is a tremendous honor, that's
why I will continue to
focus on chicken.
[Music]
in
Indonesia, vital is still considered
satanic music, so Satanic music is
black music and is considered yes.
really
[music]
it's breathinwater Indonesia
Wow that's narrow
[music]
because most of the people here just
work like farming and raising livestock and
Hi all parents, we hope
that music is not good for
twisting sinners World information at
the time with
me to  be Indonesian
first
love with each share the best videos
Hi, so because Feby is made up of
people with different types
of musical preferences, their soul mate Hip metal tank
is a combination of hip hop metal and
pangki up when performing normally wear a black hijab
and now here again  I'm
used identically with my music genre,
metal trash metal,
there are several media that
see Yomi as something  one thing that is
unique maybe because loud music is
juxtaposed with hijab for
a very religious country, maybe our
lizard
Benowo has also been terrorized several times
by people around like me, people
have thrown stones at me and got hit on the
head, but from our race, like a
village, you started to exist  What supports
our
plans for the future is that we
want poksindo in music to become
professional musicians who are internationally known.
Then, what bands can be
known for being consistent in their music,
and the most important thing is that they can
continue to be an inspiration
[music]
for my god, the face of Beautiful In White
Shoes the art  of the [ __ ] out
Hai
lu send Try Indonesia my wife
Alejandro know each
slide water is
[Musik]
no specific leave-in conditioner
Khair
[Musik]
howay the world
is not a
princess fashion catch
[Musik]
a breath
UC
Mini
khai
Carry
[Musik]
owned by khai making mysterious work in
progress thiskol know maybe Hi everyone
the world's most cronjob resource  site
using a